eight stands for acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome which is
caused by human immunodeficiency virus
or HIV normally our body is protected by
our immune system which is compromised
when HIV virus attacks and as a result
several secondary infections caused by
several bacteria and viruses could kick
in now aids could be propagated by
sexual intercourse with multiple
different partners without proper
protection it could also pass from
mother to it's baby sharing injecting
apparatuses like needles etc it can
allow to like propagation of AIDS now
once a person has AIDS what is the
diagnosis of AIDS and how aids could be
diagnosed diagnosed in the clinics so
right now there are at least three
different methods by which the AIDS
could be diagnosed not only it could
tell us that whether the person is
infected with HIV or not but also it can
have an estimate about the viral load so
you would go for all these techniques
step by step to understand how HIV could
be diagnosed first of all HIV could
diagnosed by Eliza or enzyme-linked
immunosorbent assay a confirmatory test
would be Western blotting against
specific markers of AIDS and a qpcr
based analysis which would try to
understand how much of HIV viral mRNA is
present in the pressure patient sample
would tell us about the viral load or
the stages of propagation of HIV in the
infected patient patient now first we
discuss about how we can use Eliza to
detect HIV virus in a patient's blood
sample so first of all indirect Eliza is
the technique which is widely used to
detect antibody against unknown antigen
and we know that when HIV is going to
affect our body our body would respond
once by creating antibodies so if we can
detect specific antibodies against known
HIV viral proteins from a patient blood
sample then we can be sure that the
patient is infected by HIV let's just
see how it works so first there would be
microtiter plates whose well would be
coated with antigen in this case HIV
antigen for example we know that HIV
virus has gp120 so gp1 if we find gp120
in a patient's blood sample or an
antibody against gp120 in a patient's
blood sample then definitely the patient
is affected by the HIV virus and that is
why it's immune system has produced and
T gp120 antibody right so first we
should put the plate with this specific
antigen then we should put the antibody
that need to be measured and in this
case the antibody means a patient's
blood sample hopefully if the patient's
blood sample has this particular
antibody it would bind to the antigen
and once we give a probe for detection
that is a secondary antibody which is
linked with an enzyme it would it should
give rise to a color reaction and this
color reaction would in turn tell us
that the antigen was and the antibody
again this specific antigen is present
and that is why the color reaction is
developed now in clinic definitely the
patient's and blood samples would be
taken it would be centrifuge should take
out the serum and from the serum if we
see the person has the antibodies
against HIV specific antigens then the
person would be positive or if the
person doesn't have the antibody then
it's negative so if the person is HIV
positive then in the in lies that we
would see a colored reaction but if we
don't see any color reaction that means
no antibody had is there and that is why
there is no antibody in the patient
blood sample against this specific
chosen antigen for AIDS and that is why
when we
give the secondary antibody if you're
not bind don't have a specific primary
antibody to bind with to give rise to a
color reaction as a result we would know
that the patient is HIV negative so this
is how we can use Eliza for detecting
AIDS
now other confirmatory tests after this
kind of Eliza experiment is Western
blotting in Western blotting specific
Sam blood sample would be taken the
proteins would be isolated from the
sample it would be ran into a SDS page
gel and separated along molecular weight
which could be transferred onto a
membrane and this membrane would be
hybridized with antibodies specific to a
antigen let's say if the protein sample
extracted from the patient's blood has
HIV then at least HIV biomarkers like a
like let's say protease integrase
reverse transcriptase or let's say gp120
etcetera these markers should be present
now we can put antibodies against
specific markers and look for
corresponding bands in the Western blot
and the appearance of the bands would
tell us whether the virus is present in
the blood sample or not all these things
would give us an overall idea with the
virus is present in the blood sample or
not now
if the virus has gp120 then the chip
e120 could be detected by specific
antibody when we put it in the Western
blot and that would appear as a band in
the Western blot result now other
diagnostic test is qPCR we know that the
virus is injecting its genetic material
into the host T cell cytoplasm and that
would be reverse transcribed by reverse
transcriptase and that would get inside
the DNA to form
that would be getting integrated into
the host genome well it would produced
it would produce viral mRNAs a lot right
and the amount of viral mRNA would also
give us an idea the rate of production
of new HIV virus in other terms the
viral load that how much virus is
producing and what is the stage of HIV
viral propagation so that could be
detected by cue PCR reaction so it's
just extracting the blood samples from
the patient sample pit patient blood
sample so the mRNA is extracted and from
the mRNA cDNA is prepared and specific
genes which is HIV viral specific is
amplified if the amplification result is
positive that means the virus is present
and also compared to a control
individual if you compare the fold
change that would give a quantitative
idea in terms of how much is the viral
load and also an absolute quantification
give us about the concentration of the
viral mRNAs present in the patient
sample so using these three techniques
or a combination of these three
techniques HIV could be detected in
patients blood sample if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe